and right i ricky welcome Ricky Gervais
how are you how are you yeah good
we're on you I I'm good in the big chair
yes she's all grown up and yeah yeah
she's Netflix special yeah things a lot
of things have changed is what's the
special air and I'm like [ __ ] in that
season I get the buttons yeah so how are
you man good those been eating fry up in
there it's so funny I just said I ate
eggs for breakfast I just said I hope he
smelled him when he walks in it's
nothing apart it's bed yeah that's just
why would you like that why would you
it's not good for guess is it's not good
for guess it rebels in being disgusting
right and it's like you don't know and
then he's like why are no further in
show business and it's like everybody
thinks you're disgusting that when I was
thinking that much but you play the
trailer for his Netflix special so this
is the thing he chose to draw in the
people I maybe don't know him because
when you do you do a trade you dirty bit
of people to know you that right you
didn't say I need some more fun just cut
this out
I'm Jim release it was um when I got a
[ __ ]
I don't want the girl to go I want a
lovely penis I wish it was black that
was his little triangle to draw in the
general public post you know one Wow I
mean unbelievable resulting in I love it
it's almost like I had to let them know
this is as good as it's gonna get folks
and you were so great the opening by the
way I don't think we talked about that
last time you were here because it was
yeah yeah yeah so I appreciated that a
lot you were awesome you're not as good
and he wouldn't realize you improv what
I wrote I actually didn't show a lot of
what I wrote I showed what you improv
all that the thing about the little
peeled turtle with AIDS the king of gum
guzzling
they just said that we're going for
mainstream America yeah but it was so
funny good we show you the one I wrote
so I was happy to I was happy to have
that in because um I was not a Jew of
them glade in America which way they are
air freshener yeah you do get [ __ ]
stinks in here
do we have any fried for Ricky I will I
will request an airship right look at it
every morning I get used to it I mean
Oh Jane do you smell it you just said
yeah every smells and she lives with me
so what ends up happening really is just
eggs - normally I farmers in honest is
using the radiator
it's probably unhealthy but what happens
you just sit in it and you stop noticing
yeah okay well that's it I've used to it
now what we're talking about today
what's going on I saw you on on holder
and then Cathy or whoever it is and you
were talking about you wanted to be fat
shamed which was that recent you were
saying that that's something that yeah a
couple weeks ago yeah why because I
weighed myself and I'm certainly got
heavy again see this is it right so I
was thin to about 28 I was poor and thin
and then I got a job and those are my
eating years and I reached a peak about
48 and I was lying on the floor right in
a sweat I am saying to Jane I think I
having a heart attack right and I
thought it might be a stroke because I'd
eaten 11 sausages right really yeah that
I'd you better give it here
yeah and then said you got to look after
yourself and I thought yeah so I started
working out and I did it was just
working out you know I didn't really
stop anything I don't eat meat anymore
but I I didn't stop anything I still
took him like to another thousand
calories and I drink every night is it
after you a successful that you had this
on the stroke yeah oh yeah yeah so and I
lost weight I lost about 25 pounds and
that was it right but now I still eat
and drink too much but I physically
can't work out enough yeah because I'm
getting old and my daughter
so I'm steadily getting bladder and I
suppose I put 10 of the pounds back on
and so I said the people right it's just
if we slow fat showing me and they were
sending in tweaks to me it's hard it's
hard to keep it off because I've also
lost weight so I know you was a fact
that will thing won't you I was a pig oh
yeah okay yeah no like a little you I
tell you like you like you know look
I've always thought of you more of an
amphibian or a human you know that right
yes and you used to be like a Fat Frog
Johnny disgusting fat frog and at first
I thought oh my god this this guy I'm
going to read about this guy in the next
five years and he's in jail for
something horrendous
never been done before do you know I
mean like I know this is humanly
possible yeah I know the 14 a real
killers are asking to move wings in that
and in the something like reprieve in
them out yeah right yeah and then he how
did you get fit same way you did I just
got sick of it and I started eating
better in the gym and I wish I had a
better reason that was it I just started
working out and just being aware of it
but the hardest part is when you put
five pounds back on which everyone does
we all can do it it's stopping the
bleeding and going okay just stop it
always does always that addict thinking
like I'll [ __ ] it I've already blown it
let me get the harness watched online is
still sort of stubbornness because I did
it all without giving anything up and
that's getting harder now yeah so as I
say I physically can't work out like
Rocky anymore because I ache I ain't you
know also your tab ilysm goes down when
you get older it's still no excuse so
it's still as simple it's still simple
science if you take in more calories
than you burn off you problem why it's
as simple as that right what are you
eating if you know you mean anymore what
are you eating that's putting on weight
like what do you become you know I study
you know bread and pasta and cheese and
all those things I'm pretty healthy you
know I try and eat protein I do all that
but then I have a bottle of wine every
night yeah it's just like that sugar
right 36
um spoonfuls of sugar in the bottle of
wine apparently so it's the craziest
waste of colors right but it's wine its
alcohol is worth it makes you feel good
no yes yeah I don't go after the second
bottle either okay I'm fine that's the
real fuel but you don't look fat though
with all the fat think you look great
luckily I didn't throw away all my big
black Peter the trick is to start
drinking wine during the day and then
that way during the day and I'll notice
that your fatty I think burn off more
don't you because you're staggering
around drunk I yeah burn calories but
that's I just figured you'd be too drunk
to realize that you're bad during the
day is it but yeah is the the hobo clam
basically you drink but you walk the
streets so that that burns and is the
hard part
wander aimlessly and they are in
calories and shouting and swearing and
kicking boxes that is 200 calories
unclutch the core when you yell yeah
when you put on a shirt that used to fit
like you start to notice it's a slow
thing to like you put on like gives I
size ones in size zeros and I threw out
a lot of my ones I'm like no you're not
going to give these to grow back into
you're going to feel if you start
fattening up inside yeah and zeros of
what I thought only dresses come inside
zero in size one and well we all have
our lifestyle changes as you know they
do these teachers say where it's very
fancy redwood but the one and zero and I
was the zeros and they fit me but then
after like a few weeks of being shitty
like after I shot my special in December
but that you know you shoot you reward
yourself a little and then you start
putting it on you feel it grips the side
yeah yeah it's real light and it's real
light and the next time it just grips
the under the kitty a little bit starts
and before you know it you have to go to
size one well if you're referring I was
having titties yes I am you know
something's wrong immediately okay can I
tell you one time I had a girl say that
to me she called my chest tits she was
being degrading and then she licked my
nipple and it drove me crazy and she
like oh you like your titties licked and
I went crazy it was socially I think it
was more so humiliating yeah and call me
this conversations gone downhill pretty
quickly I really is I so nor to safety
was there a nice thing about how ready
when once this girl was degrading me
well that's right at YouTube that's
right the Netflix trailer work that is
see that is where I'm I didn't imagine
Charlie Rose just going oh that reminds
me of a very funny thing happened to me
yesterday Charlie Rose is going it's
like when you get picked on right yeah
what are you doing I'm betting he does
something he lays down with his mouth on
it goes all make the rostral that is lie
better than we have no information I was
just a guest you have to get your gnarly
right I really rose theories I tell you
one thing if Charlie Rose did sue me the
funny part it would be worth getting sue
for just to have the deposition if you
have any gold please I can't wait
turning out any siblings is mr. new and
why you must obey it
mr. Lauer have you ever been urinated no
I've never been urinated I we all we
have to call in people he slices every
well worth it has he ever said to you
make the road gross yeah that would be
well worth it I think so
but when uh when I was sort of losing
weight I think I lost the weight and I
lost 25 pounds in about like six months
just really going for it and it was
between the first two Golden Globes I
did and I remember the since I sort of
had I'd take into the sort of dry
cleaners repair shop and take an inch in
I took them in again took another inch
and it was great and then when I got
back again I'm too embarrassed to take a
back row take the in sound again they
just be my wardrobe basically it's a
varying sizes of these suit because
that's time to buy new suits but you're
not going to have them taken out of the
question thing about clothes
yeah you have to buy new ones how good
does it feel when you can go shopping
and then like all the sudden things that
like a shopping is always a nightmare
because by anyway though it's Jungian I
mean I was I was I was happy that I was
sort of fit and you know things fit me
and I wasn't sweating so much but I've
never I've never really cared about that
I've never I gave that up at 28 about
fashion or looking good or I just want
comfort
I'd be happy you know you know I'm in
jeans now which is a bit of a pain to me
I'd rather be here my vagina's in fact
I'd rather be in a bucket for as my
that's it in your brain please red red
wine by an Irish Ampata bucket right
another want to seems being like yeah no
I really Caligula said wine by some
extent
yeah unbelievable
so yeah that's um and that's also it's
it's so relevant you don't going to see
me on one of those documentaries anytime
soon being airlifted to hospital lane
there's a big there's a there's a big
gap yeah
oh is a huge gap yeah I'm a what you get
a ticket to the compliments to you get
addicted to people going hey you look
good and like all the sudden that became
a motivator people who don't see you for
a while I told you when Ozzy came in and
I didn't
I didn't think he knew who I was I'd
interview him 50 times but he would
never and then he remembered me and
realized I'd lost weight that motivated
me for three years the fact that he
recognized that I do it they doing
someone on Twitter says oh she's a bat
fire oh yeah what
yeah well yeah you bet hundred now that
you know how many AIDS accusations I've
gotten on Twitter
oh so we said that to me I look ill yeah
ill I can't win no what do you want
order or like Yuri or the minute like
you show a photo of yourself skinny
didn't you used to be funny yeah on you
if I get the next page that died of a
heart attack yeah so you're not that's
ridiculous that's of this amiss as well
and they don't really they don't really
we hate ourselves as much now as before
just for different reasons we myself
into okay I didn't particularly care
I was know wasn't going on my god I
enjoyed I enjoyed food more than being
healthy as simple as that it was a life
choice I was never I didn't have any
excuses but oh I don't remember being
that worried about it what is the
hardest thing for you do not eat what's
the hardest thing feel like what's it
like what's the food that you're like
[ __ ] I can't not eat this I mean because
I'm in here the first thing I thought of
saying was caught me I know I understand
the arms and I thought to meditate
anywhere I would not that would never
pop into my head you just say oh it'd be
funny to say [ __ ] this GMR consider one
Johnny Rose so Ricky what's the what's
the one thing you can resist Enoch Scott
okay come back and we cut that know we
all know Charlie he oh I hear you
Charlie Rose I would love to see his
face it was like Vicki not cooking are
people like now might have to work again
very well Oh - mainly [ __ ] but she would
probably laugh at that though they see
my favorite white undershirt on NBC are
you got that I draw and s you talking
about a mile chicken right then you
could say it yeah yeah well that's what
I was talking about how to male 2 I
don't like the female chicken they don't
taste as good thank you
um those are so hard the hardest food
somebody [ __ ] well the hardest food to
give up it's obviously it would be any
alcohol that's not strictly a food
I'd like I like them I like
savory things I like what everyone likes
because we're mammals I like I like
fatty salty foods I like you know I mean
cheeses and and pastures and things like
that I don't think that that's me the
hardest thing and I'm not cut down on it
is your green room have a lot of stuff
in it like I'm on the road I had that
pretzels take it out of my rider
literally K my road manager would hide
the pretzels yeah they sent me I'm
finding when that's the other thing as
well when you graze when there's things
out when there's like bag of bowls of
crisp route you eat you eat with it 9
bags a crisp you wouldn't open 9 bags
right and eat them at home so I do a
little trick so I've got protein crisps
now which is they take just like crisps
but they they're they're like a way but
um so it's not it's not the taste it's
not as bad yeah so it's like 100
calories instead of 200 so you do little
tricks like that and then I suppose I
try and have a a proper meal I so have
like protein and vegetable but I've
still got the palate of a fiber deep
down will same you know I I D if someone
said we've just found a white pizza
isn't that me and I deep eats all day
it's literally all over these ok good
is there anything better than tasty
delight I love to myself a little treat
tasty delighted [ __ ] rules choices
life it's like you're frozen yogurts
roll yeah all the things better than
frozen no there's not there are there's
many things but I don't even fault I
can't have ice creams too much right
yeah putting rules yeah I know
yes I was going to work what the
euphemism is okay my writing wrong where
we going nowhere in prison what would
that mean to one's pudding reinventing
our Charlie Rose pub said rather cold
did someone say pudding when Charlie
Rose and Jim get together you got to be
careful what you say yes - how was your
tour going by the way promoting the
humanity world tour and Ricky Gervais
Compton is most of it is sold out across
the yeah well we're putting two new
dates on and there'll be the last two
dates another one in New York in October
which goes on sale this this Friday at
10:00 a.m. and and also another one the
dog
the third one at the Dolby Theatre in
Los Angelenos on sale at 10:00 a.m. in
LA this Friday so the last there the
last two to go on and yeah pretty much
everything else is sold out straight
away I've heard it's an amazing tour
amazing reviews I want to say ray is
really going well it's gone the best of
any tour I've ever done I think and I've
enjoyed it more I really I really enjoy
being a stand-up now I think I'm a
stand-up for the first time really yeah
I think I know that sounds odd but I've
seven years off so the anticipation was
good I worked on it for a long time and
thought about a long time so it is I
think objectively better but I think I
think more it's about the attitude and
the way I approached it
my first thought I felt that I wrote
them I wrote like an Edinburgh show you
know I wrote a theme show and I went out
and and practiced it almost like an
actor playing a stand-up yeah I feel
like they were more like one-man shows
they all at one of my shows and this
I've stripped it down it's me I walk out
in a pair of jeans and a black t-shirt
and I just talked them and I did more
warm-ups than I ever did before
and I did it by walking out and just
talking to them I didn't have a I had
the title and I had some things to talk
to him in it and I made sure that there
were no expectations you know that
anything you know and I just talk and
honestly it it just feels better and I
do I do
I think I can call myself a stand-up for
the for the first time well I think the
thing with you I saw you years ago do
stand-up and what was impressive about
it is you were very comfortable and
natural on stage you like a lot of guys
who just start standing up are only a
few years in have a certain performance
way and you were much more natural than
I was even way farther along in so you
had that going for you as a comic you
were very comfortable just talking to an
audience I've always felt that oh I've
always felt that I could talk to her I
mean even if it was like a crowd of
mates in the pub or yeah I mean yeah
I've always done it I don't think it was
natural I think that I've been
practicing my art for 40 years without
realising it was a job generally yeah
and also when I approached stand-up my
my my mission statement was to try and
be as funny as you are in the
do you know I mean yeah right so I
didn't want it to be - yeah Trixie or I
play the slide persona because I always
do that anyway I do that we do that here
you know so yes you know it was saying
the wrong thing for comic effect way
naughty or trying to get people to laugh
at things they didn't know they could
always doubt in taboo for that reason
because I think it's more exciting sure
you want to take the audience to a place
that hasn't been before no I mean yeah
and get them the lab things they didn't
think they would enjoy exactly and this
show is all about that it's all about
you know there are no bad subjects for
jokes it depends what the joke is you
know we've talked about this yeah you
know and and I talked about the most of
you subjects and I discussed them and
then given examples of joke then by the
end they're cracking up and then knowing
they get it they sort of get oh yeah if
I if you start off with a joke in that
subject it's gone why has he done that
because they don't know where you're
coming from and that's the other thing
about this tour and people know me now
so they know what I'm doing did you know
yeah that's really like a mate knows you
don't mean it
these five thousand strangers every
night no I don't mean it right do you
know they yes they say that they so they
know what they're in for they know it's
not like four and they love it and it's
almost like going always always done
this but I don't think we quite got it
before right and we can't get you are
the few a-list celebrities I'm going to
say a list celebrities who doesn't back
off when you're criticized for a job
which I love
yeah you never back off when you're
joking about something and people are
like I don't like that you basically
come all right well then don't follow me
you don't have to like it or if they're
insulting your insult like you handled
it really well well I think that's
because I can justify it I'm not one of
these I'm not gonna comedians it goes oh
it was just a joke because ah you know I
don't really do that I think that I
think it has to stand up on its own
you know comedic legs and I talked about
this that you know offense is often
caused when people mistake the subject
to joke with the target they don't look
at the joke they just they just they've
been told this ridiculous dogma that
some subjects shouldn't be joked about
which is which is a nonsense and and I
get asked is there anything you won't
joke about and I think well you're a
journalist is there anything you won't
write about right right it depends
what you write and it's funny because
whenever I've done a joke about a really
contentious subject or you know and it's
discussed on the radio the next day I'm
going but you're talking about it yeah
you're talking about it but because they
assume I'm coming it from the wrong
direction because I'm mature as you went
punching down and I assume I'm making
fun of whatever the victim is in this
joke right isn't true because a joke
about some it doesn't have to be pro or
anti it can be either it can be neither
it can punch nowhere it can be a pun
right you know it right it doesn't it so
every you have to take every single joke
on its merit and I got I recently got
and again you can't I've talked about
this on the show before but I was
recently on Twitter I did a Caitlyn
Jenner joke which wasn't even nasty and
I was accused by a bunch of people being
transphobic right
this is least 15 minutes in my new this
is a 15 minutes in my new stand-up about
and not even about that and all I talk
about in my spare I gotta choose to
being transphobic it was like wow you
really have no idea who you're talking
about doing what exactly oh yeah they
picked on the wrong person there but I
did Joe at the Golden Globes and those
owners transphobic and I said why and it
was about a trans person I said well
that's like saying a joke about Bill
Cosby is racist right rap ends what the
joke is it wasn't transphobic at all it
you know the joke I told at the Golden
Globes I came out and I said them all
the actors are looking at me all
nervously brilliant and I said some
relax I'm going to be nice tonight
I've changed not as much as Bruce Jenner
sorry and I go now Caitlyn Jenner and
what year she's had became a role model
for trans people everywhere bravely
breaking down barriers and destroying
stereotypes she didn't do a lot for
women drivers for something that is
clearly serious I yeah by the way like
the most the thing that people should
even if they're going to take umbrage
with something it should be like wait a
minute wasn't that a thing somebody died
in that car accident yes but nobody
except I though I discuss I say that
let's not forget the target of the joke
is it Harry killing someone in their car
they also said you dead named Travis
reminder you dead named back in October
on involves dead Naima which is ever
saying that her old name and it's used
to be a man and I say but she was I and
I do it they
about she was in big games and I act out
you know and so and but I say you know
and I know and and I was letting you
know my second crime was saying that
he'd change because they say the you
know that she hasn't changed that she's
always identified as woman and so that
you know she had transit gender
realignment and I discuss it in the I
discuss all the criticisms of me and
then I say my piece because I think it
can be funny to deconstruct particularly
when you're the butt of the joke or
you're you know and so I do I always try
and keep it fair I don't ever do a
sleight-of-hand where I say somewhat
that's a lie or to make myself look
better in a joke right you know I think
that's really important I think that and
then you once you've done your best and
you've explained it well people are
still going to make their own mind that
they don't have to like it they don't
have to get it but someone not getting
your joke isn't your problem it's their
right they always say oh sorry say okay
they only say like well you should tell
a joke that people your joke you'd
better and say why you're never any
responsibility on the [ __ ] the idiot
with ears that took it wrong brilliant
but it was idea that's brilliant why
isn't your was once we need to get the
[ __ ] joke yeah it's a great and the
other thing I get is when whenever a
like in the in the press a joke of mine
is discussed as being offensive I don't
mind that at all but when they get the
[ __ ] joke wrong that drives me mad I
go well no that's not the joke I said
isn't a good joke I joke it should be
perfect it's like a cryptic crosswords
of every word matters it's a little
piece of poetry right so if you get one
of those things wrong you can [ __ ] the
whole joke so say you have a news anchor
paraphrasing of what he was pretty much
saying was me like no yeah no well I do
I did it I did a joke I'm years ago I
say I'm um I hate I hate drink-driving I
think it's terrible I was grew it when
it wasn't a cigarette now it's terrible
and by the way I don't even drive so in
this jokes everyone knows [ __ ] I say I'm
I did it once I took the car out and I
was drunk one Christmas but I learned my
lesson because I nearly killed an old
lady and I go in the end I didn't kill
her in the end I just write the joke
there it's clearly the magic act with
I need I swerved in nearly killed her so
what I actually meant well I attacked
her so much that she nearly died from
her end and it turned out worse right so
they're discussing that Joe was terrible
right so in the papers okay they tell
the joke of this I went out and I nearly
killed no lady in the end I didn't kill
her I just raped her so don't tell
anything about the drink-driving behold
others go it's same as think what he's a
mania that week this one right now
really killed old lady be just right
there without Mary Jo that's not even a
[ __ ] joke I know exactly confessing a
crime so yeah arrested that's that
really made me laugh that was really
[ __ ] funny though it's been say
everything matters I mean live I even do
the you know the the mime of the
steering wheel and I do know lady and so
that's plant it's firmly in their head
and then you know that the surprise at
the end you know it's the ultimate
mystery I hate to break it down like
that but that's really what sometimes
it's a misdirection I didn't even do
this and then what you've done is more
barbaric or worse and that's what the
joke is about a rape it's about doing
something even worse when you're trying
to admonish yourself I didn't do
anything wrong I mean you don't of
course well if that that's exactly and
also um uh we've discussed this before
when people say oh you think you think
ranks funny they mean jokes about right
but they're they've done that little
sleight of hand on purpose to make you
back yourself into a corner like you do
think makes funny
the answer's no of course that no one
finds [ __ ] raped by me and I do this
live as well not even rapists find rape
funny there's no there's never a case of
someone giving evidence going
it was dark he was wearing a ski mask
and he was giggling know what but but
they try and the answer is again it
depends on the joke right you know I
really break it down it's it's it's so
much fun it's such a great platform to
be able to put your side forward and
discuss humor in a in a funny way and so
they're you're taking them along with
you all the way you're explaining their
hearing every word right from your side
and then that you know and it takes a
long time to explain what humor is to
someone if they are freedom of speech
you're it's it's we talked about on the
show it's crazy that we've gotten to a
point where you have to show how the
trick is done again I mean you have to
pull the curtain back there can
be anymore fourth wall like you have to
take them behind the CSA this is what I
did this is my intention this is why I
put this here like you shouldn't have
but no you shouldn't have to but this is
what the reason is the more and the more
terrible and emotive the subject the
harder it is to get over the hump about
a joke about it right yeah we can joke
about you know people joke about murder
and people get it like a murder you know
which is a horrendous murder but they
but they they can't take that personally
because they haven't personally been
murdered do not I mean where is right if
you do something that touches someone or
group of people and it's you know it's
very very emotive it's hard fun to get
over that the number of times people
have seen my stand-up and I've had one
complaint um I did the first time I
played Madison Square Garden I got a
complaint from a Jewish society saying
we love the show we loved all that so we
weren't we were however unhappy about a
routine about Anne Frank and they tell
me start as a week but you've got the
jokes about famine and cancer sure right
and you've got those in acid I'm doing
the same thing with her as I did with
those things I'm saying the wrong thing
and they went oh yes yes okay we
understand it I sometimes but sometimes
it do do need that and I don't I don't
begrudge people for now but because
because they're not attuned we think
about these things every day
a 30-second joke we probably put three
hours work into it do you not I mean
yeah about it or introspected or so and
we are presenting them with a finished
item but that's the tip of the iceberg
and so sometimes they do have to get
over there it's hard to by definition to
see your own blind spot because
everyone's got their thing they don't
want to joke about people think that
because they things are you ever
offended by things I know I'm offended
every day I'm offended by loads of
things you know it's not I'm not immune
to being offended you just don't want a
penalty imposed well if you're exactly
yeah
yeah I'm avoid the things you're
offended yeah that's the other thing
about so people think that they have the
right because they don't want to hear
something bad but it's their right to
shut you up as opposed to it's their
right not to listen and that's the
confusion as well
I think going back to the your point
that you originally made about Ricky
being one of the only people on his
level to stand up for himself right to
not apologize for every night Chad and I
stick by what you say do you think
that's partly or that I'd say fully
because you're aware of your ability to
create meaning you're not really
beholden to anything like Asian or no
you create your own material no it's not
that I think I'm bulletproof or I don't
care what I can't do anything about it
although that all those things are true
if I'm not if I'm not breaking the law
and they're not coming to my house who
cares it's virtual right no it's not
that it's that I'm confident in that
I've done right I don't think I've done
a really bad thing and I can get away
with it [ __ ] you I think no I've done a
right thing here I can stand I justify
every one of my jokes as an okay thing
to do do not I mean yes I'm not I'm not
saying because that doesn't make sense I
can't say yeah I do bad things but so
what I wouldn't do them if I thought
they were bad things so uh I I'm
disagreeing with them that what I've
done is a bad thing
just do something yeah totally I try and
get across to view other jokes about a
bad thing isn't the same as the actual
bad thing
it's not even condoning the bad thing it
could be aunty the bad thing otherwise
it wouldn't have satire and irony so you
do see so many people though and I think
that's what you're talking about Jim who
like well even though you can tell they
don't believe it go you know at first
this wasn't my intention but I saw it
from your perspective and the apologies
come out they're just trying to get the
bad story away get the bad story away
yeah well so I think sometimes it
depends some people are just trolls some
people just want to ruin your day they
get in the way they jump in the way of a
bullet and say why are you shooting at
me
yeah and I think I love to be martyrs oh
then yeah everything's personal I don't
even know they're following me I don't
know these people I'm just tweeting and
they take it they take it personally oh
why you twit I'm not tweeting you you've
you've come to my house knocked on my
door and said like why you open to me
well I'm not as you know again people
and it's hard because people think the
world revolves around them do you know
there's been people have said things on
Twitter that annoyed me a lot yeah of
course and and they're people who have
made statements publicly
myself from responding because I realize
and I really practice I'm like they're
not talking to you you're not following
there you go what the [ __ ] businesses in
the mind what they say on to it I've
actually quite I get the instinct or I
tell someone to go [ __ ] themselves
because what they say but I've backed
off on doing them again I can I hope you
get that when they they've added me and
they've misunderstood some right said
yeah and it's aggressive and you know
yeah and they make assumptions they make
assumptions about you that are wrong and
then they go through hypocrite Oh will
know the assumptions wrong so are you
going to take back the hypocrite bit now
right you use you know but again the
best thing is to ignore it because
you're right
it's one it's one idiot in this basement
and it goes away it does go away amazing
that it got it go you ignore it was
consumed consumes you can do you and
then it just disappear it's virtual yeah
it's spiritual it's like a bad dream
okay if I'm not come into your house and
you haven't broken the law it's yeah
forget it
were you surprised when you when you
posted that photo because you'll post
photos of the big game hunters and stuff
the war hunt and then say sarcastic
things about them but like recently oh
you put that photo of the giraffe and a
bunch of people thought you were posting
a photo of yourself yet killing a
giraffe and bragging about is this idea
in a [ __ ] pith helmet right with a
rifle standing on a giraffe neck right
grinning right
and I said yay I just shot a slow-moving
14-foot herbivore with a high-velocity
rifle alright
and then most people got it where we go
why'd you do that it was like a wide
shot yes we are serious like or I should
actually phrase it that way if it was
you like who would say like I just shot
a slow-moving herbivore you'd never say
that if it was no no so using and I jump
to the people that object and they don't
follow me stay there only about me so
it's obviously been arty Don - they're
there - I - I just ignore it I'd rather
you do you do in and then it shacks you
to realize that maybe there are some
people on Twitter they don't know what
the word herbivore means well that's the
other thing as well stupidity I can't
get over
I can't get over all stupid some people
are willfully I mean ignorance that
people are happy with their their anger
yeah and I think it's based on a
falsehood that's the thing about stupid
people they're very confident because
they don't know they're stupid
they have no idea yeah right yeah what's
that what's that effect of something
Kruger effect that more stupid the more
arrogant you are because you've built up
a sort of delusionary wall around
yourself to protect your thoughts and
ideas and it said this fan is
fascinating that stupid people are very
arrogant
yeah they don't know any better because
they missed a bit of the brain that
tells them they're wrong right so it's
itself absolutely don't tell me I'm
wrong I'm Lisp you must be right and
everyone's wrong because I know I'm
right right I know I'm I'm so smart and
I so stupid I don't know that I'm
[ __ ] stupid right you know it's a
lovely it you know they are the most
hated people too they have a blinding
narcissism and and they're stupid and
there's they're so hateable but the joy
in it is and here's the little asterisk
that makes me smile is they're miserable
because they don't know why everybody
hates them yeah that's kind of fun like
they're not going to stop doing what
they're doing so they're going to
continue self-destructing indiegala well
I think that if someone says I see some
hateful or stupid on Twitter all I do is
I look down their timeline about what
they're tweeting about and and what
where what's in their bio and I think
about retweeting it and at some I do but
then I start feeling sorry for them
immediately
yeah I know my god this guy's got no
life at all why with all he does I was
over in his day more by retweeting him
and it sort of vissa
I get very Buddhist yeah because you
know they aren't they they are losers
yes they are but what's better than a
video boxer confronts troll I love I
went down the YouTube world Instant
Karma and bully get owned I know I watch
those so if someone will open there's
one there's one that's at a party and
there's like they're like a bunch of
posh kids like 20 year olds or summer
and in his ones that guy is going [ __ ]
you dude [ __ ] you [ __ ] come on
come at me
me and he's doing this is what you don't
come at me goodbye and the bloat just
just poked him in the throat when you go
sorry nothing better than seeing a
little kid with a giant backpack on
getting shoved and shoved and shoved and
then he just
I know [ __ ] them and not flat I always
loved the guy that when the body picks
on like a nerd
it was like a black yeah we drops a
knapsack you know jujitsu yeah yeah it's
good I'm drunk get knocked out so easily
easy unconscious on their feet it's
great yeah yeah scary to watch though
because you realize how many people out
there like could knock you out like when
a drunk is going like come on come on
and you're like that guy would frighten
me if I was out and if he gets knocked
out easily I'm like I don't even know
how I bluffed my way out of something
because I would try to be unlike you
know loud and in and a bluff my way out
of it but I wanted getting knocked out
so this is I just don't talk [ __ ] what
does the answer is knit dog [ __ ] you
know there's the but IVs people that
again they don't think like that and and
alcohol obviously if you're drunk is dis
nothing to do about it
you get hecklers at any point I mean I
I'll deal with them once in a while but
it's fun heckles they're not even mean
heckled so I'll say that what they like
the thing is I go out I've got two
spotlights in my face there's 5,000
people there if someone shouts them I
didn't hear what he said right
so I ignore it and then people think
always annoying heckles have you heard
I've had issues the Ricky you know it's
not a heckle right right you know no I
don't get hackles and they're sewing all
the way through because I you create
that culture whether I'm it's one way
one my conversation I didn't I never I
never invited that I don't I don't do
crowd work I don't really I never grew
up in that that bare garden where it was
fun to get a drunk and present you don't
put him to shame you don't show him he's
drunk they're happy to be part of a show
often they think they're help destroy a
heckler and they come at the bar
afterwards and say oh it was great you
know we did it no we didn't do it no you
were in India yeah yeah I smashed you
and that was that part of it I don't
want to give anyone the satisfaction of
being part of this show
things happened oh you get so zoned out
you don't I've told this story before mm
Caroline's one time and after the shows
like did you see what happened I'm like
no and the guy had taken out his dick
and pissed on the floor in the middle of
my set and he was just drunk he wasn't
even being he was literally sitting
there with me being sexy for you yeah no
not at all he's even try to get my
attention he kept hidden wanted he was
enjoying the show so much
Jimmy was on the floor Jim was upset
because he didn't get to go out and leg
up the party yeah I wasn't going to say
that my senses I did have a picture next
to the puddle
because I told me they threw him out it
was a whole thing I saw none of it on
stage and I have a photo with the puddle
I took a photo with it just so it was a
real thing that's a nice things happen
that you have no idea they're happening
in the audience yeah no exactly right
but yeah that's that's annoying but I
was happy that I was really honored that
something like this happened yes there's
somebody insulated that much they don't
want to leave how great is that I would
do email he didn't want to go to the
toilet so he just never get out I got
self arrested while I stood up if he
couldn't miss one joke yeah I want you
out one joke all right maybe this is in
a blackout had no idea what it wasn't
right put on you Stevie
I wish Mel Gibson better you by the way
I know if I've seen you since him we
might have asked you about that and we
interviewed you last I just saw you or
not and I maybe I think I think he was
coming into a you know I think it was
difficult for him because I don't think
he wanted to be there we had a film out
you know it was he's had a rough ten
years I think he wants to forget it sure
I think he did his best to laugh it off
and laugh it off but I'm not yeah I
think he I heard an interview that he
was you know I don't if he said that
comically that is our yell I I wanted to
kill him you know I think people don't
want to be reminded of stupid things
they've done that's all not in that
world comedians for the rest of their
lives could be shown on for something
cuz for some reason we can handle it but
but a lot of times a guy like that was
not used to being made fun of it I used
to ridicule yeah I'm not kidding of
course well you know it's the a and the
privileged position the fact that you
know the way spoke to the police officer
stated that how dare you arrest me yet
yeah I didn't pick up on the worst
things he's done the tape was a
girlfriend Jesus I didn't even that was
too that's too dark for me to bring up
do you not I mean we literally did a
year on the radio on those okay
yeah I would I was doing sort of light
entertainment ribbing yeah we all get
drunk we don't say to our girlfriend you
know I mean like I didn't even go to the
darkest points of his yeah so it's you
know but yeah no one wants to be the
butt of a joke even if it's gentle
teasing because some people get to do
they they think they're above it they
think that no one has a right to make
fun of me I've won I've won an Oscar and
by the way not [ __ ] true we've talked
about your about the David remedy which
was life on the roads are so good which
is the animal er the album I listen to
with no irony like I just genuinely love
if you don't live for the lyrics it's
actually a pretty good even the lyrics
are fine like I even you know there's
another handily no they don't make fun
of disabled when I go this is our song
for Bruce to be singing you got it yeah
yeah yeah when I quite Smith see though
isn't it quite Morrissey please do it
from the disabled yeah that could be a
Smith song and record yeah oh yeah yeah
I mean look they were obviously but you
listen to them in the 91 line we are
like wow the person singing this
seriously is a dope like he'll say one
line angles but like God red means
exactly he means in serie he thinks it's
great he thinks he's Bruce John Cougar
Mellencamp he thinks he's bowing
clouzot an amazing I also like you
probably because we my family lives in
England for a few years when I was
growing up and my dad like after when
you perform Slough for us live my dad
called me and he was like do you
remember going to Slough and I was like
no I don't remember red brick jungle I
think it was Bill I think it was built
as a sort of town to have working-class
people do you know moved out of London
and start up like industry and stuff
everything like this is not this it like
nobody would write a song about will
that happen oh you know it's a really
romantic beautiful burden sort of Radio
ahead of all will you of the song about
about being close to Windsor but the
property's less yeah and is accidentally
dissing it you know or the critics say
it's cold and the lifeless in grey or
whatever that's my favorite line
don't with a critical critic I know it
doesn't you know forgiving Sir John
Betjeman to write about it in the
fifties that's a chopper a Nevada is
that like David Brent would hear
somebody like perform this beautiful
song that's an ode to their town whether
it's like New York City or any of these
big cities and then it's like he's like
yeah no no my my city the same exactly
yeah yeah
you choose to music by the way started
do you choose the music like for uh for
extra isn't for the audience I love that
the theme songs were amazing yeah um in
fact Jane played me the handbags and
Gladrags years before I was a great
great track by Rod Stewart we couldn't
afford that version we had to rerecord
it with a sound-alike
wait was that a radio guy who did your
version who sang the version you guys
have big big George Wembley right that's
right he sort of produced it and we got
a singer who could do a Rod Stewart um
sort of it's so good and yeah we
recorded yet and then um and it's funny
because uh I was it was either that or
sitting by Cat Stevens which I loved and
we couldn't afford that either or we
didn't get permission for that but then
we got permission to use tea for the
Tillerman which was oh yeah I ever
bought I just think it just it just it
just worked well you use a small
proportion of the songs to in an odd
portion like in like the office starts
with this just in the middle of the song
it's so good yeah because it's it's so
melancholy and and uh yeah your version
is just a ROG to its version I actually
I prefer the version you have a hers
I mean his is very good but I actually
prefer the one you have maybe just cuz
I'm used to it and I associated with the
show it's a little bit sort of solder
isn't it yeah like just yeah especially
when you're seeing a guy with a [ __ ]
with a hat that has like you know tooth
holders for beer and a radio station
thing on it have an excuse for roof
you're like most fun do the most fun
just trying to go through your day until
you die it's insane I mean yeah it's it
isn't it yeah that's what most people
that's what we all do we try and we try
and them
make exciting days more frequent than
the most boring days but then we die
it's still the best portrayal of that
guy of that person who wants to be funny
who wants to be and yet it's believable
like there's too many people that do
like fake awkwardness and it feels fake
like oh no that's awkward shut up you
know you're good-looking but that feels
like a real guy yeah well I think I
think what what people realize was it
was an affectionate look at David bent
by the end
Uncle Tony I think they realized that
well actually we're all a bit like that
that is all of us we all do that and I
think that's why people identify with it
it wasn't just them laughing an idea it
was deep down they were going I've done
that yeah well I want to give him a hug
when we find I work in yeah hug yeah
sorry he's getting wild I got away with
it every day and I get away with it cuz
I'm not being filmed right you know
right the thing the guy when you're
reading a paper in season two and just
this [ __ ] awful speech and the guys
phone rings and you like turn it off you
don't listen you're not going to enjoy
it well I thought I got that right so so
when we we lived in a within United I go
enjoy it this it's this disguising this
tension like he wanted he still want
everybody to have a good time right but
it's he's so tense but it's not
happening all that happens right well
about 1985 we went to a little local
fight in this area called Kings Cross it
was a little local fight and it was a
shitty little thing right and they had
nothing there tombolo and it was the
mums making the thing and there was like
you know loads of like toddlers and
six-year-olds running around and then
they all gotten down there's about there
was probably about 15 kids sitting down
like 15 six-year-olds right and this old
guy his name was I won't say he's now
he's must be dead now I doesn't matter
right he had a little Punch and Judy
show and he's about 75 and he's already
done this all his life and he came and
he's going out licked a bunch right and
this kids talking and then at one point
you saw mr. punch just slammed down and
he came out and he goes if you're not
going to listen you're not gonna enjoy
[Laughter]
six-year-olds
um I can't watch you now like I see and
that's the thing about heckle if you're
too harsh on someone with a head whole
you that you've ruined the show for them
because they didn't really get I've seen
comedians go oh really oh you [ __ ]
idiot no I think when I sit there I'll
go back I need a lack well we just seem
that you want to stab this guy in the
audience Oh sometimes we do you know
there's that's a great point there's a
weird thing when you get yelled at you
have to gauge immediately what level do
I hit them back at and if somebody yells
at the front row and they yell something
you a have to repeat what they say so
everyone knows what your might not
mistake before and he was on to them I'm
just having two legs well he said yeah
but once in a while you get a dream
heckle yeah like I was at the cellar one
night having an amazing set on a
Saturday and this shitty bachelorette
party was in the back and it was a good
show and everyone knew was a good show
and they heckle they yelled something
wrong which was basically an invitation
to be barbaric because they yelled
something so unnecessary and so
confrontational yeah so I knew I had
free range I really like to say whatever
I want watch the why you get one of
those but it's horrible and they just
yell and it's a summit that's funny or
sweet or complimentary you just just say
thank you very much yeah you don't
there's no there's no need to you know
and I never have stock put down so I
mean I remember the first time I saw a
stock quote I thought it was great then
I heard nine other people do the same
yeah is it what are really yeah you're
relying on no one ever been to a comedy
club before if you're doing those yeah
and I you've got a gauge everything but
you know I would say if you're playing a
theater and they've paid a hundred bucks
to come and see you
they're not there to heckle right so you
know to be entertained so but I didn't I
don't do those clubs so I never did
really um but I don't I don't I don't
really do those clubs so I'd put down
sorry I'm the stock to stock put downs
or whoever first came up with them is a
genius yeah whoever first said to
somebody loud in the audience hey
where'd you learn to whisper in a
helicopter yeah that was a grommet
genius who ever said that yes
and and the other one is 'm annoying
isn't it you come up for a conversation
and someone builds a comedy club around
you oh really good
hey you're bothering me while I'm
working do I bother you and you're
working do I get out of the quarter and
slap the dicks out of your mouth exactly
whoever said that yeah there's time yet
but only the first only the first time
for somebody said it first yeah and give
you with a heckler they wouldn't know
how true I know how the hell did you
know exactly I just say thank you madam
and I want madam
I'd love Jim evidence thank you mother
said anyone what scenario is it the Jim
know and said thank you madam I'll tell
you there's a pile of something on his
chest
ya know it's got matter oh yeah that all
depends on your perspective under there
yeah that's a great bumper sticker to
say if I'm cool transfer but I have to
argue with it if you call transfer we
just send in the photograph go do this
look like I'm drunk it was a crazy just
look at the first three take to the
window scrolled it away he's gone look
at this video doesn't that little guy
there in the corner he's our
transportation
look at the guy with his mouth full no
looking and looking up with gratitude
just say that's not obvious anybody
that's joy that is funny that's it he
had a wedding this is unbelievable this
is going out on air one guys did you
ever welcome I could carve out such a
niche and again do you ever catch any
ship from from young comics that were
jealous that you didn't have to go
through the club system to achieve kind
of being well-respected by legendary
comics I don't know I don't think they'd
have done it to my face right I didn't
coming come up and talk jealous of you
because that's a that's like like young
comics all I want is for like Norton or
louis c.k or Chris Rock or any of these
guys to be like yeah we can we can speak
on a level that we we can relate to each
other as comedians well I think I think
they
a mess about there's rules of what makes
you a good comedian you know it this
there's a thousand ways to become a good
comic and it's it's such a huge field I
mean it used to annoy me when whenever
ads like you know the top top hundred
comedians of all time they were all
stand-ups now that one old on what about
what about these guys are doing amazing
stuff and they don't do stand-up right
you know yeah this comedy isn't just
stand up it's it's one one string to to
a bow so I know why that happens though
because it's the purest form and you
can't hide behind anything and it's just
you up there less and less though those
days because more I find out more and
more comedians have writers you know
which is right righty Dangerfield head
writers news really well then I'll go
comics aid used to do jokes didn't they
so you know we had that you know like in
the 8th is when it came in it you know I
can work out I think I think there is no
new wave comedians they were lumped
together because they were probably not
racist not sexist right but actually I
think the big difference between old
comics and new comments is that the new
comics wrote their own material and they
told the truth over about their own
lives as opposed to that shared pool
like in the fifties and sixties and
seventies the biggest comics in there
might be ten big comics and burn and
they all shared jokes really they just
all shared jokes they know the northern
you know they and they were all racist
and sexist and my wife jokes you know
and they were comics and it was is that
they all had a thing some were weird
some of you know rude some were cockney
some were Scouts or some would you know
but they were basically just telling
real old-fashioned jokes and then the
newcomers came out and they've
deconstructed it and did other things
and and and nowadays it's rare for me to
see a comedian like then just tell
one-liners right yeah great you know I
don't do that but now I think I want to
I want to get a piece of that person's
life but you know you know any writers
no yeah no never never have you know
which you know because also I want I
want people to know everything I say is
true if I'm saying it's true it's the
truth you know and I think
and I want to see a community going oh
isn't it weird like gentlemen when
you're on the bus you have been on about
wait don't I hear yours cousins no you
were why well if you're right as was and
I think the bottom falls out of it yeah
I think so for me I've dropped I don't
write one-liners or surreal jokes and
the ones I have I put them in the set
and they go wow but I think are maybe
they think the other jokes are lies
so I've dropped them so I don't do right
I do
I I did a joke a couple of times and I
didn't like the way it set it it feels
fraudulent sometimes saying certain
things don't you're right it does feel
like I don't believe that yeah and if
you lied that time is this joke a lie as
well and I had to be all based in - I
don't worry Joe when some are but I had
a bit of bad news today actually there
my friend committed suicide
he just went upstairs and swallowed
everything in the bathroom cabinet
choked on a tampon that's so not me I'm
so fine I just thought That's not me
right it's a joke yeah and I don't do
that I can do it you know but I thought
it for the next two jokes are they going
is there a sucker punch coming
is there a gag here right and I want it
to be I wanted to take it I want to tell
a story that's what I want to do over an
hour and it's got a slight narrative
almost my stuff you know and it
deconstructing it in it I'm always
examining so it's analytical it's almost
like a little lecture that's what I do
and I think that's what I'm good at do
you know I started watching too and
again as another Ozzy Osbourne
recommendation he would one of his
favorite comics the kid so of course I
went in YouTube Tommy Cooper who I'm
talking about right or he was a really
funny really did what he did better than
anyone's ever done before he was a
buffoon a big guy who come out and he's
uh and he did jokes like I was a doctor
you know I said it's me when I do that
and he lifts his arm up and up said
don't do it in if things I know I've got
a real pain in my chest and then he put
here help you as a jack and pulls out a
window
Payne done really really tiny things
Annie do magic tricks that always went
wrong until the end so it was just he
was it was playing like it was quite
sort of postmodern because he was
playing a person who was terrible at
comedy right he was very funny it was
great wasn't it yeah it was almost like
a really modern character act but he was
you know it's just a buffoon those guys
were also very very hamstrung by content
you know like Lenny Bruce kicked through
by talking about religion and
Catholicism those guys weren't allowed
to talk about religion they couldn't
talk about sex so a lot of those guys
who did kind of intermingle jokes they
had such limited range of what was
acceptable to talk about in a club so
they a lot of times I think that kind of
another goal though wasn't it thank you
know there's any laws and stuff what was
on your career like Jackie Mason the
myth Ed Sullivan thought that he did the
[ __ ] you sign on his show but he didn't
and he had G hurt Jackie's career badly
like for years he had him banned from
television because he thought Jackie
Mason had done an obscene gesture which
he apparently didn't do I haven't seen
the set but uh you know like if somebody
back Buddhism yeah I suppose they still
happens now like I'm disgraced comedians
are ones that work for the BBC that I've
got handcuffs deal you know and then and
then they lose their job and it's like
really embarrassing whereas I think if
you do your own thing and you're you're
sort of pretty bulletproof if you're not
beholden to anyone then you know you go
where in fact you know I think if you if
you're doing stand-up and doing the sort
of I do a scandal about a terrible joke
sells tickets sure it doesn't hurt yeah
no one's going to go because those
people aren't coming to my shows anyway
right people who care about blasphemy
laws or obscenity laws they're not
buying a ticket to my show so it's it's
totally irrelevant to me I think was the
days where you were sort of owned you
know I mean yeah you know and we could
be hurt by one person not like and you
could ring right now now the biggest
broadcaster in the world is the internet
anyway so if you can't if you can't get
two minutes on Conan them and so what
you know there's eight was it 800
million people on Twitter 1.5 billion
people on Facebook you know you find
your niche and you work it how how many
people do you want coming to your show
you can so
I think people sort of live and die by
the sword
nowadays it's a lot it's a lot fairer
even with all this stifling
these lies and this political
correctness and that even with all that
there's the truth without your you know
you will live and die by your own
morality and and you know if you again
if you don't break the law I'm going to
come see this so I think we have to
break right we just absolutely to break
our bure ricky you're always amazing and
just to promote everything we need to
promote humanity world tour which is
sold out everywhere in the world except
a new show in new york city going on
sale offer it's in october it's going to
sell this Friday 10:00 a.m.
exactly New York time and la 10:00 a.m.
la time for October to do a third show
the dhobi at the Dolby theater with the
Oscars oh that's where that is yeah
that's the only chance I'll ever get to
be on that stage well please mr.
shoulders I mean I didn't even know
where I was
I'm like really Ricky Gervais com4
tickets are this V shows will sell out I
believe I'm coming to see this Sunday
you're in the night yeah and I'm doing
my own hour tonight at the fat black
pussycat around the corner from the
Comedy Cellar I'm working out the new
hour if you want to come well what's not
I know the comedy service that like the
only I think I know that I'm Caroline's
and one other there's two comedy sellers
there was one of us went upstairs and
one downstairs what's not the Village
Underground another comedy show with
same comedians and upstairs is the
Village Underground I want to do that
just for the fun of it you should it's
where Colin works out his material it
seats about a hundred people and it's an
amazing space we do they do joke there's
Monday Thursday Tuesday Wednesday Colin
will usually work out his new hours
one-man show he's not there tonight so I
love quite I heard this myth of it was
the only person that Jerry Seinfeld
followed and I heard him I spoke to him
on this show and I wasn't quite aware of
him because I'm from England and and
then I saw him on the comedian that
Jerry Seinfeld's thing and he's great
isn't he have you seen it his uh his
shows his Netflix special now
unconstitutional New York state all
right it's [ __ ] brilliant I didn't
know it I've been rediscovering like
people that I would really like I just
got the end of um Patrice just going
back and seeing everything he's ever
done I
you know others on YouTube yeah it's
amazing there's no one like him he'd
come out he'd start he'd walk out and
he'd start with the most contentious
thing and then work backwards yeah do
not I mean and then slowly as I had
never addressed winning more and more
and more anyone ever been bravely like
that you know to knock everybody out
first and then already get them but
unbelievable yeah and I'd never heard
I'd heard them in but I'd never seen any
Mitch Hedberg Stanford yeah mister so
great right got that just a brilliant
writer really funny performer yeah you
should check obviously and but you
should see Colin man his his stuff is so
you don't have the thing about college
he never ever and as a comedian it's
inspirational because he never takes a
shortcut to a joke and when you watch it
I forget years ago I was on stage at the
cellar doing some dog [ __ ] joke it was
some cheap and he walked through the
audience to the bathroom and I just hear
him go good writing lazy so the tiger
right yeah
[Laughter]
but he really he's really uh never been
watching me like this is a guy really
never ever doing what he thinks they
want he's truly and I hate to say it
sounds corny and poetic yeah but he's a
real artist in you yeah no no I like his
face which is odd thing to say with
someone who's so good but yeah Bert Lahr
he really exact I'd like to not a dude
yeah I like gum no Doug Stanhope
I love yeah yeah yeah he's he's the one
that's pushing stuff at the moment
intimating doing it from the gut isn't
he yeah and a lot cleverer than it looks
like it looks like a ran but I've been
watching him for a few years and
yourself Jim's coming on any oh I don't
know he's getting there
oh he's getting shy now yeah I might get
a compliment I wrote song by Colin and
daughters last Netflix special was like
Jim's was on another level like well
thanks it was really good
oh come on guys let's mix it with it
okay a Jim is such a good comedian he
deserves to be tied down by a jailer by
a blind jailer yeah that's how good you
yes I'll apologize to anybody who has
nearsighted or farsighted for that
should I just meant the guy cheatin I
didn't know our ugly the thing that he
was [ __ ] on what would [ __ ] on
anything but [ __ ] other just I didn't
realize that is Taylor anti-gay is
hideous puddle of humanity is getting
shadow I'm not even worried at the
mansion okay I understand myself you
know throw that thing away and leave the
[ __ ] [ __ ] off that thing's needs let the
[ __ ] that's been throwing the thing away
we have to keep the Bears and probably
Jim was Jim puts down a garbage bag and
lays on top of it to get [ __ ] on and
then just pick the garbage back up and
tie yeah that's the whole thing is that
it's not entirely true
what's the break this was the break for
we have stuff to do we have the break to
do a read when we want to do the reason
I can go you can do what you do then
what do we do then we have we're only on
the air until about 10:00 or 11:00
you get a spot you what you get people
obvious bye sir yeah I can wait so who
listens to this show right the people at
home yeah but people who are you know
mobile phones we want that little lizard
who lives getting shut upon forget to
get people to buy our phone whoo-hoo
[ __ ] advertises on this show well do
you have really we have no we have to do
a live read I can do the read now we can
talk from the few minutes we'll have to
break I'm interested in who wants you to
share it's actually a product that I
like which I good I would say that you
know I'm not I'm not drawing about you
about doing Polly about that fun it's
honestly like that's a laxative but I'm
very interested on what what CEO of what
company says we need Jim Norton to do
this well a lot of times I'll sit here
and I'll say when's the last time you
watched your home movies I'm not even
doing the read yet riders the music now
if you like I feel like most Americans
is a box in your closet of videotapes
film reels and photos so don't ever get
watched
worse they're deteriorating introducing
legacy
it's a simple and affordable way to get
your recorded moments digitally
preserved on a DVD or thumb drive here's
how it works you simply load legacy box
with your old tapes films pictures and
audio recordings and send it back I
don't know if I'd be comfortable doing
that with all of my videos so if you
have nice ones of your family Jimmy
you've got an old film reel that
involved in the stunt with a coke bottle
a mini van is waiting kick back
interesting Fatty Arbuckle another one I
can't masturbate to this now you send
these back in and you get them back in a
couple of weeks on a DVD or a
convenience some drive ready to watch
share and relive hopefully legacy Vadis
that takes care of everything and
provides updates at every step of the
process that's why over 250,000 families
have used them Huffington Post Parents
magazine USA Today and the view they're
all talking about legacy box and for a
limited time go to legacy box.com slash
rock to get 40% off your order
legacy box comma / rock for 40% off and
I really do want to use this because I
have so you so you've got all your
videos you don't want to just put in the
band all your favorite films on sort of
video or DVD or whatever yeah and you
send them off and they digitally record
them and I probably don't they probably
give you the digit record the actual
live all the things that you've done
yeah that's on a DVD or a thumb drive or
thumb drive or something like that this
way you have it and you can save it and
its legacy box.com slash rock for 40%
off and do they mean but they also mean
movies not just your home movies though
you can't do you can't do movie movies
like your Laura write happy right stuff
so it's all your home movies and things
like that that you never I see I see
how you have it unlike it like a like a
reel-to-reel or something right you can
send it off and then you can actually
watch it you got on a thumb drive you
put in a computer I found yesterday a
bunch of sets and I used to get upset at
the Comedy Cellar a videotape everything
and I have a bunch of videotapes this is
back from like 2005 when I was warming
up for more 2006 I was warm enough my
HBO special and there's a bunch of CEDAW
videotapes I found yesterday and I'm too
lazy to go through them but a part of me
thought of it so I mean almost I can
send them in and get them done just so I
can zip through on
a thumb drive and see if I ever want to
watch these or if there's anything I can
do with them ya know it's really when I
see it like a documentary about a guy
that I've never heard of and they've got
all this home footage and I think I'm so
jealous of what none of that other
videos of you when you were a kid
there's nothing nothing not nothing at
all it's like it's like mm before 2015
nothing now a billion things every day
of people filming themselves and you
know I mean yeah it's all crap
everything and yet there's nothing
there's nothing of me as a kid or no I
don't mean miss proto's I'm sure I
follow me oh yeah enough in a in a yeah
but probably 50 I've got 50 of me in the
bath from yesterday right yeah right
it's a holiday we just had a kid and
it's like everything everything is
photographed every single video taken on
every single day there's video oh it's
video the first time he meets the dog
let's video when he goes here oh let's
video him look he's cooing video it like
there is so much well apparently I don't
know if Easter or how they even worked
out but I think it was 2014 or 2015 when
everyone had a phone there were more
photos taken than the rest of history
Wow Wow yeah and that's presumably
doubled trebled yeah it's crazy how much
you know PI awful so if I want
meaningless photos what if I don't you
did duck face and tweet one you know and
then that gets and then that's how many
how does that how many that count of in
the on the internet with the retweets
right you know I mean every photo
there's a million right of those photos
and every single photo is it's this copy
copy copy copy at us do you like
pictures of yourself it's very funny
your your Instagram of your Twitter is
so funny because it's purposefully
horrible photos of you in the tub yeah
where you take photos of your face all
right you look dead and they're great
photos you like when someone says okay
give me a sexy look comfortable now
that's embarrassing it is right there
can't do that you don't never
particularly I mean well after the age
of 35 I've never take you'd like it but
as a comedian you've got to be careful
because irony doesn't come across even I
mean right it's like you don't want
people to think oh you think
oh you think you're sexy dad all right
I was laughing at me but you think sorry
you think you look a bit like Johnny
Depp in that picture don't you yeah and
that's that's the word oh no I know
you've got a little bit of you in
everyone's vein but no I'm
I suppose you I I don't just do as a
defense mechanism I when I get a picture
of me looking like a like a fat bloated
corpse I'm so proud of that yeah I've
got pictures that I'm so I Jay Jane look
at this look I did I get brilliant cut
off a little bit I've found different
angle where my stomach looks like fifty
times bigger way to turn the camera
upside down so there and I'd love it I
never thought there's an more
unflattering angle
I know angle that's even yeah flattered
and then there's a little bit of alchemy
where you do it wrong and is it you're
in the bath and there's a little bit of
foam that looks like spunk um and I can
I mean it just it's almost akin where
it's punking tell me what it's for but
the self-awareness and so far the
self-awareness of going look I don't
want anyone to think that I think I'm
sexy yes that's the death knell of the
comedian when you think you're sexy it's
like no one likes you for that reason
they like you because you're funny so
it's funny to like when we medians get
into that like I'm Han some people like
go [ __ ] yourself
yeah but then there's another part of
you when you're public eye and you don't
want to give anyone the satisfaction of
you accidentally looking [ __ ] yeah so
you know you wear shades and a hat if
you know I mean you don't want to that
you know close in on your bald spot
because you're not I'm not worried about
it but I hate been thinking they've got
me yeah I mean so what you doing hiding
in the bushes and trying to get me in my
[ __ ] pajamas do you not I mean right
you know you still go oh yeah okay I put
a hat on because I'm them you know it's
all those things that are annoying that
you have to have a little bit of pride
in yourself just because I don't want to
give them a satisfaction and those bath
pigs
if someone fit there's a bad picture of
me I go that's nothing look at this look
what I did you know what I showed you no
I mean it yeah I look pretty good there
well you own it when you own something
unless it's completely horrible but if
you own things it's hard of people to
get you on
exactly yeah yeah it's how I look but
yet this is my dick you know anti-regime
this is my this is my horrible postulate
in reptilian soft penis right right so
when you see it in in private and you
scream what the [ __ ] are you doing I've
already shown you what I've got I'm only
really hey look you knew it's just when
I take in the picture excited by that if
the Pakistanis a great stand-up but he
actually giggled with joy when I said
reptilian [ __ ] right right let's go back
to my dick I worry about my family on
this I have a couple of good photos of
my dick which I'm happy to go down I
okay okay a lot of bad ones but a couple
of real gems that are that really are
deceptive a good thing to do right as
well as a little little tip right um
with your penis right you can draw two
little eyes right there paper and cut
those out like two little eyes right put
those on the stock turn your penis 90
degrees right okay so the little the
little mouth bit is laughable to fish's
mouth sure sure you open and shut that
and the little eyes it looks like a
little fish it's just a little fun it's
like a puppet that's yeah yeah yeah you
dressed up an idea is mapped in fours
Robocop a little puppets a little fishy
yeah yeah that's why I was and that's
why I was fired for my children that's
yeah
there you go there was a misdirection
I'll travel acting as a funny that was
misdirected oh yeah yeah they work with
kids that Papik that's what that
puppeteer was doing when he told the
kids if you don't listen you're not
going to enjoy I still remember that mr.
poster 75 year old bloke scream innocent
six-year-olds I can hear where real
stuff from the office came from I could
look at literally watch a six-hour
documentary on that thing makes me
happen all the real person did that
that's when I was on the Brent Brent
speech when he's trying to win over the
Swindon not yeah that came for me
watching a open mic competition and this
guy was so bad and nervous I hated it
and there was comics with me that were
loving it yeah I was going that's a
human being up there
you don't like watching a guy honey I
can't do it i huh literally Jim's
favorite thing to watch I can't do it I
can't watch other people being
embarrassed I don't mind me I don't get
embarrassed
I want to soak up I want to save them
it's someone someone socially if they do
a bad joke and no one laughs and they go
red I just I wanted to take you I mean
ah you want to res anything right yeah a
take on our fall over
I'll go shot myself I've shot myself
yeah I can't stand other people being
uncomfortable too close to me that I
mean how do you feel about that Jim you
love it I understand his instinct for
that though I feel the same way but I
also relish in it like good yeah I do in
retrospect and then I fictionalize it
and I can live through it and it's great
so that David renting was I saw I saw it
open Mike Wright came out and he was
shaking so the audience went quiet his
hand was shaking on the mic and he came
out and he went you know when you're in
a cab and he went oh no and he got a bit
of hate from his back pocket and when no
rights I was you know I was in a cab
right and he start doing the joke and he
goes wrong and he goes right and it was
silent and it was just silence right
people to look not looking in my and
then he said I thought I was going on
last it all got so real it just got so
he is quiet and then he went uh I was
meant to do seven minutes but I'm just
going to go off now right I admit right
and then he said he ended it and ever
was quiet right and then he said and
then he said right if I never do this
again you'll know why and then he went
Cheers
and they sort of cut that and I was and
I thought I love that I love that bit I
have a friend doing an open mic spot in
the office trying to win over people who
didn't want that exacerbated anything
like that
I know it's the best sell and but real I
mean real comics do it I've been so many
like proper comics and they're doing
well and then they say you didn't like
that they loved I played it last week
and out so you love that gag I don't do
it oh why are you telling them I'm not
liking it
yeah we should it's really the bureau
doesn't want to be reminded that you do
that joke all the time anyway right
there there's sin to live in this
illusion
that's affected it's your thing I
watched you all - no there's nothing
wrong with that joke and the people do
laugh at that joke there's nothing like
you even take a look at yourselves
yeah I was working out a joke recently
and I again this Tuesday night work out
I do where you just work at the hour how
payable in dealing and I've worked at
this joke and it was bombing every time
I did it I loved the joke and I finally
asked the audience again is that type of
thing it's a hundred people you're
holding on right no I'd love to that I'm
like that joke what is it with that joke
do you understand what is it song comes
and somebody told me what it sounds like
I'm saying in the joke oh I'm like oh
what I was saying
I'm delivering it wrong it's a joke it's
not a great joke I loved it I love your
stupid peaches better speech speech
impediment is pronunciate world um you
talk like you got got in your mouth so
you didn't realize that they were
actually hearing a pretty different
sentence it was just not clear what I
was trying to say and yet candy anything
it wasn't even a great joke it just made
me so happy to say it I'm so bummed it
didn't work but it was funny when they
told me well I love the idea that you
can pay to go see Jim performance you
think you're going to see a Jim Norton
Show and you end up workshopping the
routine and it's an hour yeah but the
most of it is actually good but that by
the way that scene where you did that
scene I got to talk about one more thing
too because don't forget about watching
the making of the office were you you're
holding that paper and you sit down and
he goes David David Brent and you go
what whatever and you said whatever like
that was the most real yeah like I miss
not being a girl shop yeah response that
was exactly how I work for special I was
not only just bah bah thinking why so
it's been filmed and his nemesis is
talking to him a nice charming is just
that yeah though yeah I like going
through the worst day ever
I do like I do like what's the worst day
ever
I was very jealous by the way watching
the making of the office Christmas
special I love Jimmy Carr I didn't know
you guys went back that far was he's
driving you around correct he because he
lived in Slough that I was you him and
Stephen Merchant I think it has caught
my wait wait [ __ ] yeah
how did you know these guys yeah he he
lived in Slough I think he still lived
in Slough at that point when we were
doing it with Dean I was famous back
then as he is now I guess that's 2002
around there I know it was but it was it
was coming through the ranks
we started out about the same time oh
okay
in fact what I did my first end of a
show with Jimmy here's a guy that by the
way does kind of like very jokey
punchlines but it works for him it's
kind of who he is yeah he does it a bit
yeah he does great jokes he's very
prolific and one of the reasons I don't
is because at best it's it's so
labor-intensive to do an hour of
one-liners and all of them be as good as
the next which is nearly impossible it's
honestly I can make a joke work worked
ten minutes
you know deconstruct it and I've got a
momentum whereas if you do a one-liner
and you get a laugh and that took three
seconds you've got a start from scratch
I have another another one line that
lasts three seconds then you've got
another other Jesus exhausting it's
exhausting and sometimes and they're
really amazing and there's got no I
think I think the best one-liner
have got a bit of character with it as
well like so if you go to Steven Wright
and even Phillips they have got a little
bit of a mint and because you know where
it's coming from
now you start you start getting it
before they open their mouth almost so
there's a there is a little bit of
narrative built in and to Francis I'm
gonna do Stewart Francis now going again
he's he's he's got that is there's there
was a biggie of some one liners what
comics and the one-liner works as well
if you read them as well as they do yeah
I mean yeah it's almost they they've
taken themselves out of the equation
they've done their they've done the
syntax in the semantics and they've
handed over the joke to the world it's
funny if you just read it as well you
can't exactly and you can't own it
because it's a pun yeah you know I mean
so it's hard to protect that sort of
thing but hats off to them you know I
write one one-liner
a month and I don't hate it do you think
is that theater when I do what I do
like doing is some a special occasion
one line because they can never be used
again so I really enjoy writing
one-liners for the Golden Globes because
it's about the occasion or at that time
I can you know I can't use it again
really yeah so that that's fun for me
and if you're gonna do like young I love
the art form I do love the art form can
I do it you know it's but a one-liner is
a little story in the shortest possible
number of words yeah that's what that's
what a one-liner is really they're hard
to do to do well I am I guys with Jimmy
Carter he'll do an hour and 18 of a
[ __ ] hammers I mean he kills harder
than most comics and it's all funny it's
like it's really amazing to watch
yeah it must it you're right it must be
it must be so labor-intensive how your
mind works we have to wrap up I know
they're going to shut us off I think our
show actually ends right Travis
yes um so yeah Charles just said yes
into the show a plug Ricky properly to
our show is ending the humanity world
tour if you want to see Ricky which we
are going on Sunday for in October he's
back here Madison Square Garden October
the 10th this Friday morning tickets go
on sale for October whatever it is yet
and I am this Friday I'm sorry yeah in
October and then in LA in October this
Friday in LA 10:00 a.m.
exactly and now if you guys want I'm
doing my hour tonight fat black pussycat
7 p.m. show and the chip chip person
podcast is up and our podcast goes up to
there right yes it went up this morning
if you search Jim Norton in Sam Roberts
on iTunes or SoundCloud you can hear
Maria Bamford and Chris Gethard on our
show would this be a podcast it will be
a hype let's plug this yeah this is
actually be a party that's going to mark
people people are already going when can
I listen to this again
now when can I hear this hour and half
of dribble I can shut upon well well
it'll be on demand later today thank you
always the best to thank you guys
you